inicia el primero de enero de 2021 una
nueva relación en esencia comercial y
estratégica entre el reino unido y la
unión europea entonces este país podrá
buscar lo que ha querido ha dicho el
primer ministro convertirse en global
brittan en gran bretaña global para
empezar a hacer acuerdos comerciales con
distintos países en el top de las
prioridades está eeuu que sigue con el
acuerdo que ha sido aprobado en las
últimas horas lo primero es que debe ser
desmenuzado han sido diez meses de
negociación todavía no se conocen todos
los detalles de estas 500 páginas que
están escritas en un
el vocabulario absolutamente legal
entonces pasarán varias semanas varios
meses incluso antes de que podamos
entender la dimensión de este acuerdo y
también este debe ser ratificado tanto
por el parlamento británico como el
europeo en el caso del palacio de
westminster los diputados han sido
convocados para el próximo 30 de
diciembre un día antes de que termine
este periodo de transición para votar y
se prevé que será una ratificación
sencilla porque boris johnson tiene
mayorías bueno luisa y cuáles son los
puntos esenciales de este pacto donde
por exit qué se logró hoy
lo primero que hay que decir es que hubo
acuerdo en las últimas dos semanas se
creía que no iba a darse por las
dificultades que había por y johnson
resaltó como dices que el reino unido ha
recuperado su autonomía en leyes
fronteras aguas y en el sistema
migratorio me gustaría resaltar además
el también los derechos pesqueros habrá
una transición de cinco años y medio en
la cantidad de pesca que puede hacerse
en aguas británicas no hay tarifas no
hay cuotas control migratorio y cada
parte del país se beneficiará en un
claro mensaje a escocia que tratará de
buscar la independencia del reino unido
en 2021 y también en la frontera de
irlanda del norte también ha sido uno de
los temas más complejos en la
negociación en los últimos cuatro años y
medio